saint quentin en yvelines bientôt
peut-être à 11 et non plus 12 communes
c'est en tout cas c'est le schéma vers
lequel on pourrait se diriger lundi
maurepas et coignières ont annoncé leurs
envies de rapprochement une fusion des
deux villes en une seule commune
nouvelle
elle annonce qui a fait réagir vous
l'entendrez dans un instant a été faite
par mes deux invités jean pierre
semestre
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le maire sans
étiquette de coignières et grégory jarry
astier bonsoir bonsoir mr les
républicains ne mord pas alors maurepas
et et coignières partagent un même code
postal 78 310 des projets intercommunaux
comme une police municipale ou un centre
aquatique notamment devenir une seule et
unique commune nouvelle c'est la suite
logique des choses
finalement c'est la suite logique dans
l'environnement actuel effectivement
nous pensons compte tenu de la baisse
régulière des dotations de l'état nous
pensons qu ensemble nous pouvons agir
beaucoup mieux nous pouvons continuer à
apporter à nos administrés les services
que nous leur apportons et nous
faciliterons ensemble la cette
performance cette baisse des dotations
de l'état dont vous parlez les
récurrentes depuis 2014 c'est un manque
à gagner pour combien pour vos communes
n'aura pas par exemple alors c'est plus
de 2 millions d'euros de moins depuis
et je ne parle pas à défendre par
équation où on a perdu également peu
près 400 mille euros donc on est dans un
contexte très compliqué et nous savons
est aussi favorisée par la loi dans le
sens où la création des communes
nouvelles
dans le projet de finances 2010 8
l'aide financière a été relevé au delà
de dix mille habitants sur un plafond de
150 mille habitants donc c'est aussi une
opportunité
et comme je viens de le dire mon
collègue jean-pierre la volonté c'est
surtout de servir l'intérêt général et
de proposer à nos habitants des qualités
de service public identiques voire
meilleure qu'auparavant
oui pour maintenir ce niveau de qualité
de service public aussi peut-être éviter
de passer par le levier fiscal augmenter
les impôts locaux c'est l'unique
solution aujourd'hui
alors actuellement actuellement si si
nous considérons si nous considérons le
levier fiscal il n'est pas envisageable
globalement nous avons effectivement sur
les années à venir à contrôler et à
contrôler nos dépenses
d'accord il nous faut absolument
contrôler nos dépenses d'une façon très
stricte ce que nous avons déjà fait
depuis plusieurs années mais il nous
faut continuer et je pense avec une
union avec non pas nous pouvons
mutualiser les services ce que nous
avons déjà fait vous l'avez cité avec la
police intercommunale
nous l'avons déjà fait avec d'autres
services et je pense que effectivement
cette union nous permettra par cette
mutualisation par cet ensemble d'une
cote d'une ville de 24 mille habitants
lors de cette création de communes
nouvelles et puis ensuite une ville qui
ne demandera qu'à grossir compte tenu
des objectifs de logements nos objectifs
de démographique
je pense que nous pouvons réaliser des
réductions de dépenses globales sensible
c'est une annonce vous l'imaginez bien
qui a fait beaucoup réagir depuis lundi
melani poquet emi qui allait lui d'euros
sont allés interroger quelques habitants
de vos communes regarder ça peut être un
plus maintenant après je sais pas c'est
une bonne chose voilà parce que on n'a
pas vraiment tout ici mais à maurepas ya
beaucoup de choses que sa proximité pour
nous si peu obligé aussi actuellement 2
travailler ensemble pour pouvoir encore
plus de réactivité
bah c'est une bonne chose ça pour ça
permet un rapace à rapprocher les
habitants les uns avec les autres
des gens qui habitent à cogner arrive
enfin bloque aussi si l inverse au
commerce en plus de nous étendre un
petit peu sur le secteur et moi je pense
que c'est bien ce que les villes sont
grandes mieux mieux ça sera gérée plus
on aura de potentiel pour pour investir
et pour avoir une grande ville c'est
bien ça évite les frais je pense donc on
divise les frais par deux m'aurait pas
conyers et ça je vais que ça soit et
lincou et m'aurait pas mais moi je ne
trouve pas l'utilité su tout cas c'est
un peu plus éloigné que
et lincou et à des réactions plus
mitigées sur notre page facebook depuis
la diffusion de notre reportage lundi
sept internautes par exemple se dit
plutôt favorable au projet s'il services
publics n'ont pas ti pas aimer regrette
une prise de décision rapide sans
consultation des citoyens
un autre commentaire fait remarquer que
cette décision ne faisait pas partie de
vos programmes respectifs en 2014 lors
des dernières municipales et il faut par
conséquent organiser un référendum
grégory galeriste est ce que vous avez
prévu de consulter vos habitants sur la
question peut-être les associer aussi à
une décision finale
alors déjà il ya plus en pointe killing
est abordée et je me rends compte que
dans votre reportage est quand même
beaucoup de d'avis positifs dans la
réflexion qui est la nôtre c'est à dire
d'une démarche constructive et positive
est ce que nous proposons aux habitants
c'est une création de communes nouvelles
historique qui va compter justement pour
permettre toujours d'investir après la
volonté c'est évidemment de consulter
nos populations
on n'a pas encore déterminé la forme
mais il faut évidemment que nos
populations puissent s'exprimer
là il faut bien que nos concitoyens
comprennent nous sommes contre
l'immobilisme et nous proposons une
quelque chose de positif pour continuer
à servir nos habitants et donc nous
lançons une réflexion nous allons lancer
des concertations des ateliers de
travail dans les semaines qui viennent
avec un rythme qui va être très soutenu
et donc ce sera l'occasion de nos
habitants de pouvoir s'exprimer et dans
des conseils municipaux qu'on va voir de
manière justement et j'avais pour lancer
là dessus la marche à suivre auprès des
conseils municipaux respectifs michael
était un géant
alors effectivement la marche à suivre
nous allons avoir un conseil municipal
concernant unis si possible année le 2
mai prochain
d'accord au cours desquelles eh bien
nous allons voter le lancement des
études de prospective sur cette création
de communes nouvelles coignières mopao
mort porte manière c'est à dire qu'il
aura des lois sont les mois les mois
prochains
alors vos conseils municipaux respectifs
ensuite il y aura des informations et
des concertations des écoutes
de toute notre population au cours de la
17 mois à peu près environ à venir pour
avoir effectivement les avis de la
population des administrés il ne faut
pas se contenter de la vie effectivement
des élus mais de tous les administrés
effectivement au cours des mois
prochains
une date butoir c'est le 1er janvier
2019 oui alors pourquoi le 1er janvier
2019 pour que ce soit clair pour tout le
monde sait que la loi nous demandent si
nous souhaitons aller dans une création
de communes nouvelles de le faire avant
cette date parce qu'on ne peut pas
modifier la carte et communales un env
les élections municipales et aussi pour
bénéficier des aides de l'état
il faut que cette création de communes
nouvelles souhaite engager à cette date
mais c'est que le début il ya l'acte
politique de la création et ensuite il
va se passer des années pour construire
un projet de ministres hâtif
parce qu'il faut penser aussi aux agents
municipaux et un projet de territoire au
1er janvier 2010 halle du coup il y aura
une commune où c'est un projet qui peut
être abandonné entre temps il y aura une
commune ol lyon c'est un projet positif
c'est un projet positif et donc 1er
janvier prochain je pense qu'il y aura
la création d'une commune nouvelle
réunissant hambourg pas à coignières je
le pense profondément
et donc c'est une aventure comme l'a
précisé gregory gary astier et la
commune nouvelle sera créé le 1er
janvier 2019
effectivement ils nient leur à la
réunion des deux conseils municipaux au
sein d'une même commune d'accord jusqu'à
l'élection de 2020 the dawn pour
convaincre
dernière question vous parliez justement
des de la question des agents un
commentaire qui émerge sur facebook
également combien de suppressions de
postes au sein des services publics
c'est une question qui a été posée sur
une page facebook une fusion est ce que
ça veut dire que va y avoir aussi une
réduction d'effectifs hausse alors c'est
seule mairie c'est pas une fusion
c'est une création de communes nouvelles
et donc c'est un peu comme dans un
mariage
chaque fiancée apporte son passé son
historique d'accor ses compétences et
donc on va faire une alliance un vrai
mariage et donc il n'est pas question de
suppression pourquoi voir le côté
négatif des choses justement cette
création de communes nouvelles va nous
permettre de maintenir nos services
publics tels qu'ils sont et voire même
de les améliorer en fédérant l'ensemble
de nos compétences alors
que finalement si nous n'allons pas dans
cette direction nous savons qu'à terme
de toute façon c'est soit de la
suppression de services publics ou soit
de l'augmentation forte d'impôts locaux
et nous ne souhaitons pas aller dans
cette direction
en tout cas ça sera ma dernière question
une seule un celte un seul conseil
municipal un seul maire est ce que c'est
à dire que l'un de vous deux va se
retirer au profit de l'autre dernière tu
es certainement qu'à nous deux va se
retirer au profit de cet ordre c'est en
2020 effectivement même en début 2019
sally rabb des signes de reprise et or
l'a effectivement l'élection d'un maire
délégué d'une mairie effectivement
annexée merci à vous
jean-pierre recevait serait bien qu'on y
sert de coignières et maire de maurepas
d'avoir est avec nous et une actualité
un que l'on suivra bien sûr dans les
prochains mois avec attention sur atv 78